[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Ich habe vor einiger Zeit mal Aprikosenknödel gemacht,
Marillenknödel.
Und während des Drehs kam uns so die Idee
– okay, Josh kam die Idee,
Nougatknödel zu machen.
Und daraus entsteht das heutige Video.
Wir machen heute Nougatknödel,
das Ganze mit einem Marzipanteig.
Denn ich denke, Marzipan und Nougat
passen schon gut zusammen.
Ich weiß, du magst Marzipan nicht so sehr.
Aber darin wird es schon...
>> JOSH: Bei den Knödeln fand ich es ganz gut dann.
Ich war überrascht.
>> SALLY: Da wird es schon richtig gut.
Und dann packen wir noch Pistazien dazu.
Und ich finde, das Ganze erinnert so ein bisschen
an Mozartkugeln.
Nicht? Mozartkugel: Schokola-
– also Nougat, Pistazie und Marzipan.
Und es gibt sogar Mozartknödel.
Aber ich glaube, da nimmt man die Mozartkugel,
also dieses süße Teilchen,
die Praline,
und packt die in einen Knödel rein.
Aber wir machen es heute ganz anders.
Also mal gucken, wie wir vorankommen,
wie das passiert.
Vielleicht frittieren wir sie auch.
Wer weiß?
Ich zeige euch mal kurz die Zutaten.
Dafür nehme ich
500 Gramm Magerquark,
150 Gramm weiche Butter,
zwei Eier,
100 Gramm Marzipanrohmasse,
etwas Vanilleextrakt,
400 Gramm Mehl
und eine Prise Salz.
Bei der Marzipanrohmasse verwende ich hier Edelmarzipan
mit Marzipanstück-
– mit Mandelstückchen.
Und es sind 62% Mandeln.
Also da ist jetzt auch nicht viel Zucker drin.
Daher wird der Teig jetzt auch nicht megasüß.
Und ich glaube, das
wird schon gut.
Also das packe ich mal weg.
Und hier müsst ihr jetzt gar nichts beachten.
Haut einfach alle Zutaten in eine Rührschüssel.
Doch, die Butter muss weich sein, das müsst ihr beachten.
Aber das war es auch schon.
Zwei Eier.
Und mein Marzipan ist auch recht weich.
Das zerbrösle ich so ein bisschen.
Man kann es aber auch einfrieren
und dann ganz einfach reiben.
[Musik]
Dann Salz und Mehl.
Und die Zutaten einfach kurz verrühren.
[Musik]
Das war es jetzt erst mal.
Und jetzt räume ich hier kurz auf,
hole meine Backmatte und mein Nougat
und dann wird schon direkt gekugelt
– geknödelt.
Was klingt besser?
Gekugelt oder geknödelt?
Klingt beides komisch.
Ja.
>> SARAH: Beides wirkt zeitlos.
>> SALLY: Beides auf seine Art.
>> AYLIN: Gerollt.
>> SALLY: Gerollt.
[Musik]
Jetzt habe ich hier mein Nougat.
Den schneide ich kurz klein.
Eigentlich wäre es besser, ich hätte Nougatkügelchen.
Aber ich habe keine.
[Musik]
Dann ein bisschen Mehl.
Und direkt den Teig auskratzen.
Also, da das Rezept so an sich recht schnell geht, Josh,
würde ich schon sagen,
so mit dem Frittieren, wir probieren es.
Was soll der Geiz?
Also ich brauche noch ein bisschen Mehl bei mir.
Wahrscheinlich, weil es ein bisschen größere Eier waren
als sonst.
Nougat.
Ich versuche, es mal ein bisschen zu formen.
Aber...
Doch, geht.
Das dürfte schon größer sein, gell?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: 25 Gramm. Passt.
>> JOSH: Ist gut.
Wobei, das ist dann schon eine viertel Tafel Schokolade.
>> SALLY: Also 25 Gramm Nougat in 80 Gramm Teig.
>> JOSH: Ui!
>> SALLY: Guter Schnitt.
Und dann zu einem Knödel verschließen.
Also ich glaube,
das wird lecker.
Doch.
So machen wir das, Josh, okay?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich meine, man kann sie auch kleiner
oder größer machen, aber ich finde sie so ganz nett.
So.
Und man kann sich es auch einfacher machen.
Ihr könnt zum Beispiel diese Nougatstückchen,
die ihr euch abwiegt,
formen und dann kurz einfrieren
oder in den Kühlschrank stellen,
falls sie eben zu weich werden.
Aber so passt es eigentlich gut.
[Musik]
Hier sind jetzt die fertigen Kugeln.
Ich habe jetzt schon mal einen Topf mit Wasser aufgesetzt
– das darf jetzt ganz kurz aufkochen,
später aber nur noch sieden –
und, weil wir es vergleichen wollen,
noch einen Topf mit Fett.
Das wird jetzt erwärmt auf etwa 170°C.
Und da werden wir frittieren.
Beim Frittieren bitte immer aufpassen!
Kein Wasser ins Frittierfett geben
und nicht reinfallen lassen,
auch keine Tropfen.
Denn dann entsteht eine Stichflamme.
Also da müsst ihr wirklich aufpassen.
Ich werde auch gleich beides separat machen,
also getrennt voneinander,
dass nichts passieren kann.
Dann habe ich jetzt hier noch ein paar Zutaten,
die ich noch brauche.
Und zwar etwas Butter,
Semmelbrösel,
Löffelbiskuit
und Pistazien.
Die Löffelbiskuit und die Pistazien
einfach noch kurz zerkleinern.
[Musik]
Meine Arme!
Ich habe Pamela-Reif-Arme.
Ich habe noch so Muskelkater.
[Musik]
Ich bin gespannt.
Du auch?
>> JOSH: Ja, schon.
Na, los, Wasser und Fett
und Butter!
Na, los!
Ich gebe noch eine kleine Prise Salz zum Kochwasser,
auch wenn es ein Dessert ist.
[Musik]
>> JOSH: O mein Gott!
>> SALLY: Was machst du da?
>> JOSH: Ich wollte den so ein bisschen...
Dass der...
Weil der...
Ja, nee. Jetzt liegt der ja nicht mehr in der Linie so.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Zur Butter gebe ich jetzt noch
die Brösel und die Pistazien.
Und dann einfach gern so ein bisschen durchrühren,
ein bisschen mit anbraten.
Ich kontrolliere die Temperatur des Fettes
jetzt hier über den PerfectCook von Bosch.
Da habe ich einfach die Stufe 5 eingestellt.
Das sind direkt 170°C.
Ansonsten wählt ihr einfach
etwa die mittelhohe Stufe an eurem Herd
oder benutzt eine Fritteuse.
Auf jeden Fall sollte das Fett nicht zu heiß sein,
aber auch nicht zu kalt.
Und ihr könnt testen, ob das Fett heiß genug ist,
mit einem Zahnstocher oder Schaschlikspieß.
Ihr stecht den hinein
und dann bilden sich so kleine Blubberbläschen.
Bei mir ist die Temperatur erreicht.
Ich habe den Piepston gehört.
Und da jetzt das Fett zuerst bereit ist,
werden wir halt erst frittieren, Josh.
>> JOSH: Oh, schade.
>> SALLY: Das Wasser braucht noch.
>> JOSH: Brauchen wir überhaupt Wasser?
>> SALLY: Das sehen wir dann.
Okay. Ich hoffe, es klappt jetzt einfach.
Und...
[Musik]
Beim Frittieren müsst ihr wirklich aufpassen.
Ihr dürft da auch nicht zu viele Kugeln auf einmal reingeben.
Denn dann kühlt das Frittierfett ab
und das Fett fängt dann an zu schäumen.
Und wenn es schäumt, läuft es auch mal über.
Ist mir schon mal passiert,
als ich İçli Köfte gemacht habe, also so Bulgur-Frikadellen.
Und ich habe mich echt gewundert,
warum das schäumt, als wäre Spülmittel drin.
Und es war wirklich, weil es einfach zu kalt wurde.
Und das ist gefährlich,
wenn dann das heiße Fett dir so in die Küche läuft
auf deinen Parkettboden und so.
Kann Flecken geben.
Es hat Flecken gegeben.
Ups!
Wollen wir es wagen?
Den ersten rausnehmen?
Wie lang war der jetzt drin? Fünf Minuten?
>> SARAH: Ja, so was.
>> SALLY: Ich hoffe,
der ist jetzt durch.
Ach, komm. Ich lasse den noch so eine Minute etwa.
Aber hier drüben kocht jetzt schon mal das Wasser.
Und ich werde es jetzt ein bisschen runterstellen,
dass es wirklich nur noch siedet,
und kann da jetzt auch noch ein paar Knödel reinlegen.
[Musik]
Also die im Wasser brauchen jetzt so ungefähr
zehn bis fünfzehn Minuten.
Eher zehn.
Und die im Fett, die brauchen nicht ganz so lange.
Also richtig schön goldbraun werden lassen,
eher golden als braun.
Mh, die eine lasse ich noch.
Und dann bin ich echt gespannt.
Oh, auf den Anschnitt!
Ich finde, wir sollten den Fritty Friday
einführen.
>> JOSH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ja?
Fritty Friday?
Alles frittiert, alles wird frittiert.
[Musik]
Also die frittierten sind fertig.
Sarah dreht schon durch.
It's not Fritty Friday.
Aber wir werden einen Fritty Friday einführen,
an dem wir alles frittieren.
Ich habe mir so gedacht,
wenn Gewitter im Kopf zu mir kommt,
dann könnte ich frittieren.
Aber dann dachte ich mir so:
"Nope, zu gefährlich."
Zu gefährlich.
Okay.
Die hier brauchen noch ein bisschen.
Also die in der Fritteuse, die brauchen ungefähr
fünf bis sieben Minuten
und die anderen ungefähr zehn bis fünfzehn Minuten.
Wir probieren jetzt erst mal die frittierten, oder?
Komm!
Ripplinger, Palik,
die Frittiertester.
>> JOSH: Wird auch Zeit.
[Applaus]
>> SALLY: Ripplinger.
>> JOSH: Zur Stelle.
[Applaus]
>> SALLY: Palik.
Palik, Sie müssen zwischen uns
>> SARAH: Ach so.
>> SALLY: zwecks Mikrofon.
>> JOSH: Ja, Ton.
>> SALLY: Also, da die...
>> SARAH: A!
>> SALLY: Da die frittierten
außen eher ein bisschen trocken sind
und nicht so nass...
>> JOSH: Wenden wir die jetzt einfach trocken
oder machen wir die noch so mit Butter?
>> SALLY: Wir wälzen die jetzt trocken.
Wir wälzen gar nicht.
Wir tunken die dann.
>> JOSH: Ah, okay. Tunken geht.
>> SALLY: Wir machen da jetzt nicht noch...
Also, Josh, jetzt geht es aber los.
>> SARAH: Jetzt noch Butter drauf?
>> SALLY: Jetzt noch Butter drauf?
Wir wollen gleich noch Sport machen.
>> JOSH: So sparsam, wie du mit Butter immer umgehst,
>> SARAH: Figurkiller.
>> JOSH: da
würde das gar nicht gehen.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Los!
Ich glaube, ich würde noch Vanille-
>> SARAH: Du schneidest bitte auf.
>> SALLY: Ja. Ich glaube, ich würde noch
Vanillesoße dazu reichen.
>> SARAH: O mein Gott!
>> SALLY: Nicht?
>> SARAH: Doch.
>> JOSH: Schokoso-
– Nougatsoße?
>> SALLY: Oh, wow!
>> JOSH: Ui!
>> SARAH: O mein Gott!
>> SALLY: O mein Gott!
Und dann so von denen.
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ich habe es echt zerstört.
>> SARAH: Ja, okay. Ich nehme das.
Du kriegst das große.
>> JOSH: Oh ja!
>> SARAH: Heiß?
>> JOSH: Okay.
>> SALLY: Ein bisschen.
>> JOSH: Ich sehe es schon kommen,
dass ich mir den Mund verbrenne.
>> SARAH: Ich mir auch.
>> JOSH: Ich muss kurz warten.
>> SARAH: Ich mache es ein bisschen kleiner.
>> JOSH: Pass auf, dass deine Kette nicht im Nougat hängt.
Oh ja!
Komm schön her.
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> SARAH: Boah!
Hm!
Mmh!
>> SALLY: Also man muss sagen, der Nougat ist halt
– übertönt halt alles.
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> JOSH: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Aber
>> JOSH: Oh ja!
>> SALLY: übertönt alles gut.
Und ich finde...
>> SARAH: Ohne das andere probiert zu haben,
ich bin Team
>> SALLY: Oh!
>> SARAH: Frittiert.
>> SALLY: Und die Kruste!
>> JOSH: Die Marillenknödel sind gar nichts dagegen, hey!
Das ist richtig...
Ja, okay. Die sind auch...
>> SARAH: Frittiertest bestanden.
>> JOSH: Ja,
Frittiertest.
>> SARAH: Ripplinger.
>> JOSH: Palik.
Frittiertest bestanden.
>> SARAH: 10 von 10.
>> SALLY: O mein Gott!
>> JOSH: Hammer!
>> SARAH: Hm.
Mmh!
>> JOSH: Also die Pistazie dazu zum Nougat,
>> SALLY: Und
>> JOSH: wahnsinnige Kombi!
>> SALLY: nicht zu süß.
Also ich finde tatsächlich
>> JOSH: Hm.
>> SALLY: die Kombi mit den Löffelbiskuits super.
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Denn ansonsten würde mir etwas Zucker fehlen.
Frittierfett ist jetzt fertig.
>> JOSH: Okay, halb-halb.
>> SARAH: Hm.
Hier, das ist deins.
>> SALLY: Ich hebe das Frittierfett noch auf,
falls wir morgen noch mal was frittieren wollen.
>> SARAH: Wir wollen safe
>> JOSH: Falls?
>> SARAH: noch was frittieren.
>> SALLY: Also wir werden noch mal frittieren.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich werde das nur einmal durch so ein
Kaffeesieb da geben,
dass die Teile hier weg sind.
Und dann kann man es ruhig noch mal benutzen.
Und nach zwei, drei Mal benutzt man Frittierfett nicht mehr.
Das heißt, da gibt man es dann abgekühlt in eine Flasche
und kann es im Restmüll entsorgen
oder sogar bei so einer Sammelstelle abgeben.
Also jetzt holen wir noch kurz die nicht frittierten.
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ihr seid eigentlich schon megaglücklich, nicht?
>> SARAH & JOSH: Hm.
>> JOSH: Mh.
Das war ein Fehler.
>> SARAH: Gell?
>> SALLY: Ah, es war ein Fehler, die zuerst zu probieren.
>> JOSH: Weil eigentlich – die können jetzt nur noch verlieren.
>> SALLY: Ach, komm!
>> SARAH: Es kann nur schlechter werden jetzt. Ja.
>> SALLY: Ach, komm. Wir geben ihnen eine Chance.
>> JOSH: Okay.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Und da mache ich es jetzt so:
Ich gebe sie jetzt einfach tropfnass
direkt hier in die Masse, okay?
>> SARAH: Hm.
Der kommt hier dann noch drauf.
>> SALLY: Josh, willst du noch mal kurz
Kameramann spielen?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Kannst du das
>> JOSH: Ich mache ein Schnittbild.
>> SALLY: als Frittierexperte?
>> SARAH: Willst du uns dann noch mal neu ankündigen?
Soll ich auch noch mal?
>> SALLY: Ja, komm.
Ich kündige euch noch mal neu an.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Meine Damen und Herren,
Ripplinger und Palik, die Knödeltester.
>> JOSH: So.
>> SALLY: Und da hätte ich jetzt bitte gern einen Applaus.
[Applaus]
>> JOSH: Wo sind die Knödel?
>> SARAH: Da.
>> JOSH: Gut gesehen, Palik.
>> SARAH: Gern geschehen, Ripplinger.
So. Das war meins.
>> JOSH: Ja.
Oh, wir waren hier schon mal.
Passt.
>> SARAH: Déjà-vu.
>> JOSH: Ja, voll.
Krass.
>> SALLY: So.
Jetzt darfst du anschneiden,
während ich noch meine Knödel hier aus dem Wasser fische.
>> SARAH: Sieht auch schon mal
sehr, sehr gut aus.
>> JOSH: Oh!
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> JOSH: Hat auch was
>> SALLY: Hat halt eine...
>> JOSH: dadurch, dass die halt so hier weiß sind und so...
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SARAH: Und so grün außenrum, gell?
>> JOSH: Ja, das Grün.
>> SARAH: Also optisch, wie viele Punkte?
>> JOSH: Nicht schlecht. Oh, schon 9 von 10.
>> SARAH: Ja. Ich hätte auch gesagt,
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: 9,5 von 10.
>> JOSH: Oh, sogar 9,5.
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> JOSH: Ja, seit wann vergeben wir Kommanoten?
>> SALLY: Und die kannst du halt einfach so...
So.
>> JOSH: Okay.
>> SALLY: Ich wollte halt noch ein bisschen Pistazie.
>> SARAH: Jetzt bin ich gespannt.
>> SALLY: Heiß.
>> SARAH: Heiß?
Du bist Vortester.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> JOSH: Und sind sie genießbar?
>> JOSH: Okay, dann, Palik.
>> SARAH: Ripplinger.
[Musik]
>> JOSH: Mmh!
Oh!
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> SARAH: Mmh!
>> JOSH: Überraschend.
>> SARAH: Hm.
Mh!
>> SALLY: Oh!
>> JOSH: Heiß.
>> SARAH: Boah!
Sind warm.
>> JOSH: Und?
>> SARAH: Oh, ist das...
>> JOSH: Geht es?
>> SARAH: Oh!
>> SALLY: Woah!
>> SARAH: Ich habe mir die Speiseröhre verbrannt.
>> JOSH: Okay.
Ja, berufsunfähig, Palik.
Tja...
>> SARAH: Machen wir weiter als Anwälte?
>> JOSH: Okay, ist auch gut.
>> SALLY: Oh!
>> JOSH: Anzeige ist raus an den Knödel.
>> SARAH: Oh!
>> SALLY: Also...
Wow, mein Hals!
>> SARAH: Hm, meiner auch.
Der ist verbrannt.
>> SALLY: Ich habe mir die Zunge und alles verbrannt.
Okay.
>> SARAH: Ei, ei, ei! Das heiße Nougat!
>> SALLY: Lasst die Knödel ein bisschen abkühlen.
Also, was ich persönlich sagen muss,
mir gefällt da bei den frittierten der Crunch,
weil einfach außen die Kruste.
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Aber hier bei denen finde ich tatsächlich,
dass man das Marzipan besser rausschmeckt.
>> JOSH: Hm.
>> SARAH: Ich finde die weicheren auch besser tatsächlich.
Das ist jetzt ein Schock für alle,
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: aber
>> SARAH: ich bin auch Team Gekocht.
>> JOSH: Es tut im Herzen weh,
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> JOSH: weil ich finde es eigentlich witzig,
einfach was zu frittieren.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> JOSH: Das war der einzige Grund.
Einfach mal sagen: "Komm, wir frittieren die Dinger."
>> SALLY: Das war eigentlich der einzige Grund.
>> JOSH: Aber geschmacklich
>> SALLY: Aber schmecken tun die mir besser.
>> JOSH: sind eigentlich die gekochten besser.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> JOSH: Muss man sagen leider.
>> SALLY: Ist halt die...
>> SARAH: Wir haben schon 10.
Wir haben schon 10 Punkte vergeben.
Was sind die?
>> JOSH: Nein, 9 und du 9,5.
>> SARAH: Nein, nein, nein.
Für das Aussehen von denen.
Aber wir haben für die 10 vergeben.
Für die frittierten.
>> JOSH: Ah! Aus!
>> SARAH: Was machen wir jetzt?
>> SALLY: Und jetzt?
>> SARAH: 10,5.
>> JOSH: Wir werden Anwälte,
>> SALLY: 20.
>> JOSH: nicht Knödeltester.
Wir sind unqualifiziert.
>> SALLY: Mh.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Also man kann es ja schon mal ausprobieren.
Ist ganz witzig.
>> JOSH: Es war den Versuch wert.
>> SARAH: Ja, auf jeden Fall.
>> SALLY: Aber ich finde, Knödel gehören einfach
in siedendes Wasser.
>> SARAH: Gekocht.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SARAH: Megalecker!
>> SALLY: Megalecker!
>> JOSH: Aber trotzdem, die Variante mit Nougat drin
und Pistazien drumrum,
>> SALLY: Und Marzipan.
>> JOSH: Hammer!
>> SARAH: Ich finde, man sollte erst
die Aprikosenknödel essen und dann die
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SARAH: als Nachspeise.
>> SALLY: Hm. Definitiv!
>> JOSH: Woah, krass!
>> SALLY: Also probiert es gern mal aus.
>> JOSH: Dann brauchen wir noch einen Knödelsalat als
>> SALLY: Knödelsalat?
>> JOSH: Vorspeise.
>> SALLY: Frittiert sie einfach oder kocht sie,
so, wie ihr möchtet.
Das Rezept findet ihr wie immer in meiner App.
Und wir werden
– ich werde die zwei Produkttester weiterhin
mit einspannen
und werde ihre
>> SARAH: Wir sind Allestester.
>> SALLY: fachkundlichen Kenntnisse zurate ziehen.
Ripplinger, Palik,
herzlichen Dank!
Bis zum nächsten Mal!
>> SARAH: Gerne. Gerne.
>> JOSH: Danke schön. Jetzt...
>> SALLY: Und euch viel Spaß beim Nachmachen!
Tschüss!
[Musik]